the city of New Orleans is fast becoming
a global hotspot for the virus it's
roughly 1,200 cases are rapidly growing
and the latest figures show 57 people
have died in surrounding Orleans Parish
giving it the highest death rate in the
nation almost four times that of New
York on Friday Governor John bel Edwards
said the city's Convention Center is
being converted into a potential field
hospital with 240 beds being set up this
weekend the last time it served that
function was following Hurricane Katrina
as in other places New Orleans famous
restaurants are closed to diners and are
now serving takeout only that means
there are far less there's far less food
waste in the alleyways for the local
rodent population to feed on and that
has driven them out into the streets
Omar Villafranca reports the party has
paused on Bourbon Street to cut down on
crowds and flatten the curd bars and
shops are closed in New Orleans famed
French Quarter now the only late-night
revelers are rodents looking for food
this video shows rats in the middle of
the street focused more on survival
Bible than social distancing the French
Quarter is known for its food its
cuisine so it's a place where if your
rat it's it's heaven Charles Marsalis
shot the video of the vermin the local
businessman says rats have been running
around the quarter for centuries but
he's never seen them scurrying around so
boldly I turned the corner there's about
30 rats at the corner feasting on
something in the middle of the street
had you ever seen anything like that out
no never you know you know you see this
mayor Latoya Cantrell says with many
restaurants closed in the quarter the
rats are looking anywhere for a meal
it's driving our rodents crazy to
control the population city crews have
started putting bait in the gutters and
placing rat traps all over the French
Quarter Claudia regal heads up the Pest
Control Board she's worried about the
infestation and possible infections rats
can spread to the city's homeless
population
fortunately we don't see many of the
health outcomes right we don't have very
many disease cases that are actually
related to rodents but the potential is
there the new reality of empty streets
and staying at home is not only hard for
some people it's hard for rodents
fighting with each other for CBS this
morning Saturday
Omar Villafranca New Orleans ya know and
you worry about other diseases yeah